聊了怎么赚钱吗 赚门能让我们变得越来越好
这是一条非常简单实用的干货
但是不知道为什么 我之前拍了一条视频结果被线留了
我记得想了想 我觉得
我在拍一遍 因为他对我们真的很有用 而且简单有效
但是我也不知道他为什么就就线留了 所以我尽管他小今年你自己去思考
有些时候不能说的那么明确
我建议你真的花点时间 认真的去看
然后看看那些东西可以在你的生活中把它用出来
我们的时间和经历是非常有限的 所以我建议大家不要花那么多时间和经历去学那些所谓的用的知识
你应该花更多的时间和经历去学习那种
学了一次就中身受用的知识和技能
而不是那种花了很多时间和经历
学完了只用一次
或者是学完了以后 根本就用不到的知识和经历
你为了什么呢
对了 你的时间和经历真的真的是非常有限的
有此推论
我们应该去做那种
做了一次就可以中身受益的工作
而不是每天都要清零每天都重新开始的工作
结果之前给大家分享的另外一句话
如果你自己没有方向 那么你每天都在实现别人的方向
我们大多数人是没有自己的方向的
所以每天都在努力实现别人的方向 且每天做完了以后都会清零重新开始
就像是那个不停旋转的
对吧
那么怎么破局呢
所以我说这个
世界观很重要啊 就是你怎么理解世界他就会决定的行为
就是我们大多数人只有一条路行
就是我努力的学习
然后一路学然后考大学找费好工作
对了 走个好工作
然后的慢呢
努力工作
再考个证
再往上考
然后再工作
对吧 很多人就这样 我不说不行啊 但这条路很在呀 人也多呀
其实是有另外一条路行的
比如说很多人都知道我是中中逼业
这些很多人的很多人的现实啊
我现在可以明确的跟你说而且好不惨规的跟你说好不切剧的跟你说
我是中选逼业 我的文品不高
但我的文化
可不低
我不知道这么假 你能不能理解就很轮把文品等同一文化
这是非常愚蠢的
那么这个世界就会有另外一条路
就是哪怕你文品很不高
但是只要你能给这个社会给他人创造价值
你就能获得收益
你和使用你创造价值的那个人
你们俩都会因为这件事情
变得更好
这是一个说一样的事这个世界是可以说一样的是可以共一样的
兄弟们
那是很多人
做这一切这一点包括很多人说
我也想创造价格怎么创造呢就很难会现在那种很大的许识里比如说我做东西
就一定要做一个特别大的就是像苹果或者像特色
但是其实我们可以做一些
为止产什么叫会因此啊可能它就是个批点赋
对吧 就是个批点赋
那么比如说我之前给大家分享过
就是一个程旋
他呢就是有一段产品刚出来的时候他是没有帮助的
然后他自己就写了很多免费的文章
生活遇到问题的时候他好像就同很多朋友跟他说
其实你的那个文章都特别有
你可以把它打包成一本小车子就是一个批点赋
就是真的打包就是做成能小车子了
当然会批他原来的文章或者做得更好
结果一年转了一百多万
一百多万然后
就是个小车子就是你生活中还有很多别的小车子啊对吧
第二的话比如说还可以是模板
什么呼类的模板包括写作的模板啊
那我我不敢说了好 因为求中亿什么叫呢对吧
所以我给大家贴了土比如说他就是做的那种模板
就是生活的模板
一份财卖400多
什么财卖400多 但卖了一千多份
生活中有很多这样的模板
包括孩子开学的什么做西啊
包括一些习惯阳场啊对不对
包括很软板那种画变签
把它打印出来
它就随身险带啊对吧
这些东西都是什么大的成品
它都是一些很小的产品 但它很有用对兵有帮助
别人就会够买
就这种微产品
它是非常好的 为什么因为它构建的成本很低
就你做它你不需要画费太多时间贺
你自己你也可以做
它修改的成本也很低
然后你随时可以已经调整
对吧
而且的话呢其实也不需要那么多的用户
我们很暖手限制的
其实我们很多很多的
伟大的产品
做了非人好的产品 都是从小产品开始的
比如像客含你们知道吗
它最开始只是给它的表弟表妹露了一条视频
一条视频一片文章就可以是一个微资产
然后的话呢 你像这个RBNB
它其实就是放在两人一个生活会没有了
旁边有酒店 然后住马了
他们就像把他们那个床空气床住出去 所以做RBNB
没想做的越来越大 对吧 包括像Facebook 早期就是校圆里的一个
我觉得是一个小英用吧
就是性感吗
不性感
HAT
NATHAT
是吧 这样的一个
这样的一个校圆后来越做越大的
所以很多
伟大的产品都是从一个小的英用小的城市开始的然后变得越来越有市场
我觉得
只要这个东西对边有价值
真的对它有价值 他就会去使用
而且你舅舅完了以后 一次舅舅完了以后
其实你只要把它放在那儿
它就可以
中身的
属于
它是关于税后收入和关于
这种编辑成本的
尴尬的
一个很好的这个英用 所以大家有些人就可以尝试一下把你过往一些成功的经历
比如说你简直印象很胖
然后你简直二三十斤 然后它是很健康的简直的
你可以把它变成一个小策子啊 或者是一种方法会从产品啊 告诉别人
对吧 你以前的话你是怎么考了造假设计的 你是怎么考工的
对吧 你是怎么自许的 你是怎么是AI的
然后你是怎么从一个普通人
然后做在小生意的这些经验都可以把它整理成一个为的产品
那很说没有怎么办
你可以有
你可以有 各位听懂了吗
只要有一个有需求的东西
你把它解决的别人可能也需要
你就可以把它购建成一个为福
一次购建
中生可以收益
所以
这个不是关于一泡泡 泡红了一下就红了一下就可以争很多钱
不是这样的 就我们一个踏下心来
做一些真正有有用的事情 对别人有用的事情
然后你做成了就可以活得收益 而且你可以一个又有的去考验
然后这样你就会有的经验
然后你可以更加一些更大的东西
所以
它不是一个多么红大的它
把不会有多少人等待其实不是
它就是
马上现在开始要做的一件事情
所以我的建议是
各位
停止去等待一些更大的事情的出现
你已经等了很久了
请不要在每天从林开市的工作
然后停下来
然后每天
呈进下来几乃
去购建一个
持续
有用的这么一个服
然后把它购建出来以后的话
然后你就可以
持续的
获取收益了